Now that you're familiar with the basic R commands,
let's look at some more data. This time we'll be
looking at data collected from a survey of Reddit users.
Reddit's a social and entertainment website where users can post
links and comments about trending news. This survey asks users
about demographic information such as gender, age, nationality and employment
status. It even asks users what type of cheese they
would be. And whether they prefer dogs, cats, or turtles.
Download the data set from the instructor notes and load it into
R. Once you've done that, take a look at the data by
using the str function. Now when I try to read in the
file, sometimes I might get an error, and this is pretty common,
so I would suggest looking at your current working directory to figure
out the problem. Often times your directory isn't where your file is
stored. Alright, so I've set my directory, and now I'm going to try
this code up here again. And there we go, there's our data.
Running the str command, we can see that there's lots
of data here. Most of these variables have a type
of factor. Now, a factor's a categorical variable that has
different flavors or levels to it. An example of this
would be employment status. This variable has many different levels
such as employed full time, or employed part time. Or
not working. One thing we might be interested in is
how many people are in each group of employment status.
We can table that variable to see the number in
each of these groups. Running this code I can see the
table. We can also get these counts and other data points
by running the summary function on our data frame. I encourage
you to check out the output of this for yourself. In
addition to factor variables like employment status, the R programming language
also has other data types like list and matrices, but we
really won't be working with them in this course. We've included
a reference for data types in the instructor notes, so if
you would like to learn more about those, check it out.